Et voilà donc, j'appuie ici dans l'application.
Oh !
Ça se lasse automatiquement.
Oula, ça sert beaucoup.
Comment on fait pour dé-lasser ?
Ouais, pour l’enlever.
Alors c’est pareil, on rappuie
directement dans l’application
OK.
Ah, j’ai plus de batterie.
14h, fin de journée là.
- Ah la vache oui
- Non, non !
Non, les gars.
Mais monsieur
vous n’êtes pas là pour
votre propre entretien d’embauche
Désolé, j’ai vu un digicode en bas
j’ai paniqué et je suis parti.
Bravo.
Vous êtes embauché.
Bon les gars c’est officiel
nous avons la plus grosse
base d’utilisateurs du monde
Yes !
...de tonton et de tata.
Bah du coup,
ils sont où les jeunes ?
Ils sont chez Tiktok.
- Tik
- Tok
C’est plein de joueurs
Ils se parachutent sur une carte.
Ils trouvent des armes.
Et le dernier survivant gagne.
C’est plein de joueurs
Ils se parachutent sur une carte.
Ils trouvent des armes.
Et le dernier survivant gagne.
C'est plein de joueurs
Ils font tomber des petits blocs.
Puis on fait des petites lignes,
comme sur Gameboy
Et le dernier survivant gagne.
Je suis désolé pour ta femme.
C’est arrivé subitement.
Courage Didier.
Elle était dans son lit.
Merci pour l’abonnement.
Ça fait plaisir, installe-toi.
Elle s’est pas réveillée.
Oh, 20bits, merci !
Oh, énorme, merci beaucoup !
Et donc c’est mercredi la crémation ?
Mercredi, oui.
Ils lancent, AppleTV+.
Et Disney+.
Et pourquoi on ferait pas
Canal++
Ouais, non.
Non, mais ça va pas vous plaire.
Mais si, dit toujours, vas-y raconte.
Mais non mais
c’est de la science-fiction
vous refusez à chaque fois.
Non mais André,
dis quand même, vas-y.
- On t’écoute.
- Ça va peut-être nous plaire.
Bon OK, ça se passe dans le futur.
Et les gens doivent payer
pour avoir des émotions.
On le fait.
- Ah bon ?
- Ouais.
Ouais on le fait.
Par contre, ça se passe
aujourd’hui, pas dans le futur.
Et ça parle de racisme aussi,
c’est important.
- Avec Christian Clavier !
- Oui !
Félix tu vas au Bangladesh
filmer une caverne naturelle.
Didier tu vas dans le Limousin
filmer un kinésithérapeute, c’est parti.
OK, c’est trop hype ce qu’on va faire.
On révolutionne l’information clairement.
Clairement.
Ouais enfin...
C’est plus ou moins de la télé
c’est des reportages.
Mais ça n’a rien à voir Didier.
Nos vidéos elles sont carrées.
Et on met des sous-titres en dessous.
Ah ! Mais ça n’a rien à voir.
Didier.
Oh ! mais Didier ?
Comme les Avengers c’est terminé
comment on va faire de l’argent maintenant ?
Comme les Avengers maintenant...
Attends...
On sera terminé un jour.
Pour Star Wars
on est battu. c’est fini.
T’es parti en second temps.
Non je suis parti en first
dès le premier temps.
Bon les gars.
Le Roi Lion le remake
du remake.
Waouh !
Basile !
Basile le détective.
Le remake !
Basile détective privée.
Tu connais pas Hervé ?
Basile, Détective... aventurier.
On rentre dans la guerre !
On rentre dans le meuble.
Problème.
Réinitialisation.
Ah ! J’ai eu trop peur.
Bienvenue chez Tiktok.
OK, on l’a refait aussitôt.
je regarde l’écran moi,
je regarde pas la cam moi
Je suis un idiot.
Ah, moi aussi je regardais l’écran.
On regarde l’objectif.
Tu regardes quoi Avril ?
Tu regardes ça ou ça ?
Bah le truc rond là.
Ça ?
Ouais.
Alors t’es professionnelle. c’est bien.
Contrairement à nous deux.
Beaucoup plus que Ludo.
- Tik
- Tok
Bienvenue chez Tiktok !
J’ai regardé l’écran putain.
Putain, moi aussi.
Deux, ouais, deux abonnements.
Enfin désabonné.
Hein ?
Ah oui, un !
De ?
Ah non, un !
Hein ?
Un.
De ?
D’abonnement Youtube Premium.
Ah, deux !
Hein ?
Non, un ! C’est moi, je suis abonné.
Mais c’est l’offre gratuite, je vais...
je vais annuler.
De ?
Voilà, zéro.
Netflix, Disney, Apple.
C’est bien, c’est court, c’est rapide.
Pardon, j’avais oublié.
Alors.
Tu t’appelles Ludo, dans ce sketch.
Milliardaires !
Oh, on a tout perdu.
Cyp, elle était énorme.
Non mais vraiment, c’est vraiment bien
ce qu’on a fait tous les deux.
J’en étais sûr !
Basile détective privée, le remake !
Ho, ça me plaît.
Basile, on met la musique ?
Basile détective privée
le remake !
Il est brûlant !
Et... action !
Squeezie.
Quoi ?
Bah Squeezie.
Bah ouais.
Bah si.
Les derniers trucs étaient pas mal.
Oui.
Quoi ?
Bah le dernier.
L’impro !
Je voulais partir sur une impro,
mais j’ai aucun terme de Twitch.
Ah, un...
Une bit
Un petit tweet.
Le mec qui connaît pas tu sais, le vieux.
Ah retweet là regardez.
Merci pour le retweet.
Et ça c’est beau.
Bon tu m’as soulé.
C’est pour qui les sashimi ?
Mais qu’est-ce que c’est que ça ?!
Julien Josselin.
Mais tu te fous de ma gueule ?
J’ai demandé des sashimi.
Pas ton slip !
Et c’est une fin de tournage.
C’est une fin de tournage ?
Mec t’as pété la table.
Abonne-toi à la chaine de Cyprien.
Maintenant.